[Musica]
sono nata circondata da l'odore del
piombo e dell'inchiostro un mix
olfattivo che forse tanti di noi hanno
dimenticato o tanti altri non hanno
neanche mai provato ma eccolo qui
per me è buonissimo e mi ricorda la mia
adolescenza quando
accompagnavo il mio papà all'edicola
locale la materia prima dell'agenzia di
stampa dei miei genitori erano appunto i
giornali
torna vara e la nostra autovettura con
due buste piene zeppe di
carta e l'auto si non dava di questo
profumo
appunto il mix piombo e inchiostro e
questo profumo io ho sempre connesso con
il concetto di lettura così come le dita
sporche le dita nere che proprio quello
che accade dopo che si sfogliano i
giornali ancor più quelli galli di
stampa
cosa è successo
che tra le mie mani poi al posto di quel
nero mi sono ritrovata a questo come
tutti voi era il 2007
in quegli stessi anni nascevano facebook
e twitter
tecnologie piattaforme oggetti che hanno
di certo cambiato tante delle nostre
abitudini tra cui quelle di dove e come
informarsi
la domanda quindi per noi diventa come
sopravvivere come può sopravvivere il
giornalismo quando il business model non
è più sostenibile e soprattutto sono
cambiate tutte le dinamiche tra
contenuto e lettore
per dare una risposta a questa domanda
dobbiamo guardare al contesto è quello
che è successo negli ultimi anni negli
ultimi 15 anni
tantissime tantissimi media hanno chiuso
i battenti così come tantissimi
giornalisti e addetti ai lavori nei miti
non lavorano più
in inghilterra dal 2005
265 giornali locali sono morti
oltre oceano il 47 per cento degli
addetti ai lavori nei media è scomparso
significa che ha trovato un altro
impiego e la metà
la metà dal 2005 a oggi
ma cosa è davvero cambiato me
l'industria dell'informazione
nell'industria della news principalmente
tre cose la prima è il contesto è un
contesto caotico
difficile da gestire che lo possiamo
definire cacofonico pieno di notifiche
messaggi
pieno di informazione è un contesto in
cui la logica del mass medium non esiste
più
un emittente
singolo che invia un messaggio
standard a un ricevente la massa
la massa viene vista come un insieme
uniforme non fatto da singoli individui
che invece quello che succede oggi
perché possiamo identificare il nostro
lettore che è un ricevente che non è
solo più lettore ma infatti lo chiamiamo
utente quindi che può utilizzare
l'informazione non la riceve più
passivamente ma soprattutto non riceve
solo una ne riceve a miliardi
i messaggi sono tantissimi per questo
appunto è un insieme caotico
i giornalisti quindi non lavorano più in
un giornale non lavorano più dentro
questo ma lavorano nelle notizie seconda
cosa che è cambiata la
distribuzione
che conosceva il lettore fino a pochi
anni fa
l'edicolante l'edicolante era quello che
parlava direttamente collettore aveva un
rapporto diretto
faceva domande soprattutto sapeva i
gusti le preferenze dei lettori di certo
non i giornalisti e gli editori che
forse li contattavano in maniera spara
sporadica con qualche sondaggio o con le
famose lettere al direttore
oggi questo è cambiato completamente noi
appunto riusciamo a comprendere gli
individui grazie ovviamente alle ottime
capacità di elaborazione dei dati che
gli algoritmi forniscono ai giornali e
quindi di conseguenza questo pone
tantissime nuove opportunità al modo dei
giornali ma anche alcuni rischi
terza cosa che è cambiata come vi dicevo
troppi stimoli ma quindi anche poco
tempo da dedicare alla informazione una
scarsa attenzione degli utenti
quindi come fanno a sopravvivere i
giornali in un contesto del genere
attraverso il cambiamento della cultura
di impresa editoriale
bisogna cambiare l'azienda che fa il
giornale non bastano più idee innovative
nei prodotti
e nei contenuti
non bastano più idee solo editoriali
serve altro serve capire il contesto
serve capire le dinamiche serve capire
il futuro quindi il futuro del
giornalismo è in mano ai giornalisti
tanto quanto ai manager
ma chi sono questi manager di cui vi
voglio parlare oggi sono delle figure
ibride che sicuramente sanno gestire
l'alta complessità di questo contesto di
cui abbiamo parlato sanno comprendere la
competitività a cui media sono soggetti
oggi ma poi soprattutto sanno gestire
appunto il termine manager vuol dire
gestore le dualità di che dualità sto
parlando vi porto nell'antica roma
agli incroci delle strade molte volte si
trovava una statua con due volti da un
lato un vecchio anziano con la barba che
guarda da una parte e dall'altro un
giovane dal volto fresco che guarda
l'orizzonte
questa è per me la perfetta
rappresentazione dell'essenza del
giornalismo oggi perché perché il
giornalismo ha una doppia
entità da saper gestire la prima come
nel giano è un doppio sguardo 1 a quello
che fa il giornale la parte ontologica
cosa stai a fare sul mercato
fare informazione ed essere baluardo
della democrazia dall'altra parte sapere
guardare al futuro guardare alle
innovazioni tecnologiche
guardare a chi saranno i tuoi
competitors seconda dualità è una
dualità di struttura nulla di nuovo qui
questo è tipico delle istituzioni
culturali in tutto il mondo da una parte
abbiamo la parte creativa
l'intellighenzia le tenne
dall'altra abbiamo chi fa quadrare i
conti chi rende sostenibile il lavoro
dei primi e un equilibrio che molto
spesso viene citato come stato chiesa
che non deve più essere visto come
conflittuale ma deve essere visto come
collaborativo chi può gestire la
collaborazione tra questi due parti
della stessa statua dello stesso corpo
questi manager
innovatori innovatori contaminati
perché sanno
bilanciare gli equilibri all'interno di
un giornale grazie a un background che
non è certificato per lavorare solo ed
esclusivamente nelle news e un
background che
imprenditoriale proattivo che sa
guardare all'esterno tanto quanto
ovviamente all'interno dell'azienda
perché la contaminazione quindi avere un
background misto e alla base
dell'innovazione
l'innovazione non è fatta da schemi
fissi tanto quanto non si è fatti da
schemi fissi quando si è figure
innovatrici
quello che vorrei che immagina ste è che
molto presto vedremo al tavolo di
redazione ogni mattina
giornalisti sedere di fianco a questi
manager manager che appunto gestiscono
la complessità voi potrete pensare ma
perché i manager vanno in tavolo di
redazione perché
quello che devono saper fare i manager e
permettere alle pmi giornalisti di fare
bene il loro mestiere e non essere
distratte distratte da tutto questo
contesto caotico di gestione tra eastern
ita esternalità tecnologie nuovi
prodotti fare bene il proprio mestiere
significa analisi delle fonti trovare le
fonti analisi dei dati nonché scrivere
informazioni di qualità dei buoni pezzi
e soprattutto ancora consumare le suole
delle scarpe andando fuori sono i
manager che devono gestire la
complessità interna sia della macchina
giornale sia della relazione verso
l'esterno verso tutte queste nuovi
competitivi competitors che vediamo e
questi manager sono un riassunto di una
nuova cultura d'impresa che dobbiamo far
nascere all'interno dei giornali una
cultura di impresa politecnica che
sappia essere sintesi tra saperi
scientifici e saperi umanistici
ma io vi ho raccontato solo di una
visione di un sogno
no è una realtà dal 2018
ho fondato insieme al mio team
un progetto che si chiama est italia
challenge quello che facciamo è appunto
cogliere accogliere nel nostro giornale
ragazzi talenti under 30 dai background
più diversi e più variegati da diversi
paesi del mondo e da tutti i continenti
non che sono soprattutto persone che
possono essere laureate e non dallo
scienziato al matematico a chi è esperto
di letteratura
ma qual è il comune denominatore di
tutte queste persone che noi portiamo in
azienda per fargli conoscere fare
respirare quella cosa che di cui vi
dicevo prima a respirare il giornale
respirare l'atmosfera
dell'impresa editoriale
loro a un comune denominatore che è
quello di vedere una funzione etica e
sociale per la democrazia nel giornale
di qualità nell'informazione di qualità
questo cosa ci ha permesso di fare in
primis di aprire le porte della nostra
azienda che ha più di 130 anni di storia
ci ha permesso di creare nuovi progetti
che hanno ispirato ovviamente sia la
parte editoriale che il business ma
ancora di più abbiamo creato nuovi posti
di lavoro perché abbiamo fatto capire
endogena mento e quindi internamente al
nostro team e al nord la nostra azienda
che con il confronto con il nuovo col
diverso con nuovi background noi
possiamo effettivamente costruire
dall'interno il futuro per
l'informazione
e quindi l'orizzonte dunque quale è
quello di pensare all'impresa
editoriale come a una nuova un nuovo
centro per l'umanesimo digitale e
soprattutto un luogo in cui riusciamo ad
accogliere talenti diversi
politecnici e costruire con loro
rimanendo baluardo per la democrazia ma
con lo sguardo verso il fuori verso il
futuro
un futuro sostenibile per l'informazione
di qualità che non è mai stato così
prezioso come oggi grazie
[Musica]